الحياه في ايران تغيرت عن السابق واصبح
هناك جيل لا يخشى القمع وادواته هكذا يقول
محتاجين ايرانيون فجموع الايرانيين تلك
تبدو وكانها اتخذت قرارها باحداث تغيير
انهم لا يخافون من ان تواجههم او تضربهم
ووفقا للارقام الرسميه الصادره عن صحيفه
جابان اليوميه الايرانيه فان ثلاثه سنوات
من المحتاجين تقل اعمارهم عن الخامسه
والعشرين واضاف معهد الشرق الاوسط في
واشنطن ان ابناء الجيل الايراني الحالي قد
حذوا بفرصه للحصول على معلومات والتواصل
مع العالم الخارجي افضل من تلك التي اتيحت
لابائهم واجدادهم
30 بنايه جميع تلك البنايات ترمي عليهم
الحجاره واذا كانت البنايه من اربعه طوابق
فجميع الطوابق ترمي ليس الحجاره فقط هناك
بعض اللقطات بهذا الخصوص وشاهدتموها كانوا
يرمون مزهريات على رؤوسنا وضربوا زملائنا
بالمكواه والبراميل ورموا علينا طاولات
وكراسي
وفي احدث اشكال قم الاحتجاجات قتل مهاجمون
على دراجات ناريه سبعه اشخاص بالرصاص
بينهم امراه وطفلا في مدينه ايزيل واقعه
غربي ايران في حين رصدت منظمات حقوقيه
اطلاق النار في ست مدن الكبرى على الاقل
وفي سجون ايران واقع اصاب بحسب المخرج
الايراني المعارض بنا بناهيه الذي قال ان
المعتقلات لم يعد بها متسع لاستيعاب
السجناء الجدد مضيفا ان الحكومه الايرانيه
المستقبليه ستعلن من سجن افين الذي يضمه
خبره وكفاءات حنان المصري العربيه